Narrator: IT TOOK JUST 18 HOURS
FOR POMPEII
TO BE BURIED UNDER MILLIONS
OF TONS OF VOLCANIC
ASH AND PUMICE.
AN ENTIRE LIVING CITY
WIPED OUT,
THOUSANDS OF ITS PEOPLE
BURIED ALIVE.
THE SUPER-HEATED AIR
BURNS THEIR LUNGS
AND MELTS THEIR MUSCLES.
THEIR TWISTED
AND CONTORTED BODIES
WERE QUICKLY BURIED IN ASH.
A TEAM OF SCIENTISTS IS NOW
STUDYING 15 BODIES
THAT WERE FOUND TOGETHER
IN THE EAST OF THE CITY.
THE ODD POSITIONS
THESE BODIES WERE FOUND
IN INTRIGUES TEAM
LEADER LLORENç ALAPONT.
Narrator: TO DO SO,
THEY'RE SCANNING THE CASTS
IN MORE DETAIL
THAN EVER BEFORE,
TAKING HIGH-RESOLUTION
PHOTOGRAPHS
AND THEN X-RAYS
OF THEIR BONES LOCKED INSIDE.
Narrator: ONE CAST IS
PARTICULARLY WELL PRESERVED.
LLORENç HAS ALREADY
UNLOCKED PERSONAL DETAILS
OF THIS MAN'S LIFE.
THIS YOUNG MAN ALSO HAD
A MILITARY SWORD,
WHICH LEADS LLORENç
TO THINK HE WAS A SOLDIER.
Narrator: THE WELL-PRESERVED
SECTIONS OF THE CAST ARE COPIED
AND THEN FILLED
INTO OTHER SECTIONS
THAT ARE LESS DETAILED.
Narrator: THE RESULT IS AN IMAGE
THAT IS MOVING
AND STRIKINGLY LIFELIKE
OF THE YOUNG SOLDIER
WHO WAS BURIED 2,000 YEARS AGO.